brett mentioned earlier in the podcast
that the renegotiation of gender roles
are long overdue
i'm curious to know what concessions he
would like males and females to make
respectively
well i mean i definitely feel it's a
privilege and an honor to be able to
negotiate on behalf of both sides
here that strikes me as very right um
no i look i think
i don't think it's that kind of a
renegotiation and i think you know this
is one of the things
i think you and i have slam-dunked this
right because our our relationship
is entirely um non-traditional
with traditional elements where they
make sense right it is
a very symmetrical relationship almost
to an absurd degree in the sense that
you know we had the same job at
evergreen we continue to have the same
job
right you can't seem to avoid having the
same role in the universe
the same access to healthcare all of
these we have the same children
thank god you know i was i was just
waiting to see
one of the children has killed the power
into the computer
i think they're a little surprised and
may be disappointed to discover that
that is in fact the case
um but no the the answer to the question
is look lots of things have been altered
by this landscape
that provides us with certain freedoms
that our ancestors wouldn't have had and
it exposes us to some hazards that they
wouldn't have faced
right to the extent that you're just
applying a traditional
uh set of norms it's relatively
straightforward and you just sort of
accept the costs and benefits that come
with them
in our case basically i'm up to see
um anybody
establish what role they want so long
you know it's kind of frankly a little
bit of
um a libertarian approach with respect
to gender roles i'm up but it's
libertarian in the sense that i would
uh and i have argued on this podcast
that libertarians
are under imaginative typically about
harm
and so the point is you should
essentially be free
to do anything that doesn't have harmful
consequences
to others but harmful consequences
flowing to others are much easier to
produce than you think
and so you really often invisible
sometimes long term just like what we
were talking about in the first hour
today
yeah you know what
what might be the long-term consequences
of introducing women into
military outfits right right um
even you know if it's not hand-to-hand
combat there's nothing about the
physical nature of the work
that is going to be compromised by the
fact that on average women are not as
strong upper body strength
might there be long-term effects that
would render such a force
less coherent in an emergency situation
i don't know
i hope not but i don't know well and it
might be different
for infantry versus you know pilots
yes right yes um very much so so
anyway there's something to be navigated
there and it is also
highly likely in fact i would argue it
is uh
very close to certain that even in
places
where it can be done in such a way that
it doesn't harm our
military effectiveness that there are
much better and worse ways to do it
and so anyway a sort of sensitivity to
you know in the case of the military i
think we have a particularly
clear case which is um this is the place
where our aspirations for
um equality and other such values
have to be secondary to our ability to
protect
the nation from harm which doesn't mean
they're unimportant but it means
you know it's just as you don't want
somebody bursting into
you know in an operating theater and
interrupting your heart surgery to
you know count how many people of
different races are in the room and
try to establish equity right right the
point is there's a
there's a hierarchy of significance
and in the case of the military
individual aspirations uh are not the
highest priority
right i keep trying to figure out how to
phrase this
right the military has in fact a
been very well integrated for much
longer than many structures
freshly integrated right now it's not
just that's not its history originally
right but the point is it has
and it was sort of like at a gross level
integrated before it was actually like
interspersed integrated right i mean
they were separate they were different
units right and then
there weren't and so there are ways in
which uh people
who weren't traditionally working next
to each other have been put in that
position and the military's figured out
how to do it and do it well
it also is weirdly like the most
socialist um entity around it
neutralizes differences between people
at many scales but then it also creates
this hierarchy so it's like
you know socialism stacked on top of
each other or something
but anyway the point is it doesn't it
you know to the extent
that the us military is fighting for
liberty
it's like an it's not an
uh it is the opposite of liberty on the
inside right it is constraining
by necessity in order to make it
effective on the battlefield you don't
want a bunch of people
you know doing their individual
calculations on the battlefield you want
people to function as a
coordinated entity and so anyway
my only point would be uh there are
places for
these discussions and there are the
places where these discussions have to
be secondary to
a mission that is so critical that you
don't dare upend it before you know
exactly how it works
yeah so anyway with respect to men and
women there's lots of room for
renegotiation
we need to be cautious about what we
don't know about what happens with all
sorts of things
you know obviously women being in the
workforce has been
fantastic the number of things women
have accomplished
you know in for example the scientific
milieu
is huge right so this is obviously a
good thing did it come without
complexity
no and in fact we still haven't figured
out all of the complexities of how it's
supposed to work
so anyway it's a work in progress and to
some degree we yell at people who try to
talk about the complexity
yes yeah absolutely